[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
managing editor of gamespot.com and
we're gonna be playing some Call of Duty
infinite warfare zombies today I'm
joined by a recurring friend of the show
Lee Ross you what what is your your
exact role in title over at the at the
team I am the in-house crazy guy also
known as the associate project director
for zombies and Infinity Ward where we
are introducing this last episode the
beast from beyond today yeah we've had
several of Li you've come on and showed
us a lot of different things from the
zombies one but this is the the final
one it's kind of rounding out the season
and a narrative a story that you guys
have also told across these different
chapters yeah this is this is the
culmination of all the efforts that
Willard Weiler has been throwing these
four characters through over this the
span beginning in zombies and space land
so here we finally hopefully fans can
survive and we will have to show people
a little bit of this today but hopefully
they'll survive long enough to find out
exactly what Willard's been up to this
whole time why he's chosen our four
heroes why were the celebrities chosen
in the past and ultimately what's gonna
happen are they gonna escape this thing
are they gonna kill Willard while or
what's gonna happen well let's go ahead
and jump into a match and we'll start
talking while we're playing fortunately
you don't have to deal with me playing
the game and dying over and over again
we will be taking the controls here on
this stream and we also have Eric Tay
and Joey joining us in the background so
Lee will try to survive today I'm sure
Eric will keep us alive our ringer back
there Eric you sports stay people feel
know this from from a lot of our games
watch streams Tay is probably our
biggest professional eSports player
across multiple games yeah I've heard to
watch out for his gamertag that one if I
see him in something like overwatch or
something I should just run so you know
I'll try to I'll try to represent today
so Call of Duty the especially the these
zombies modes I think they always
introduced a colorful cast of characters
I loved seeing Paul Reubens
did you get to work with him in the Geo
booth or get to interact with him at all
yeah absolutely we've we've had the
luxury of having a very colorful Cassidy
Paul Reubens of course joining us in the
outset playing are evil director Willard
Wyler and of course we've had a few
guests along the way that have joined
our cast of protagonists you know the
likes of David Hasselhoff and Kevin
Smith
most recently Elvira and of course Pam
Grier joining us for Shaolin shuffle and
events of the 70s and then of course
rounding out the cast playing Poindexter
we have Seth Green returning hopefully
to make his way out
Andrae being played once again by the
awesome Jay Pharoah and then of course
Ali being voiced by so she resumed Aida
and of course last but night last not
least we're gonna sorry this Ike
Barinholtz playing our character AJ that
people just love to assume he's he's up
to no good so this is probably the
closest and look to infinite warfare but
that's not because this is set in the
infinite warfare world this is a
different horror setting as we've seen
with the other chapters and zombies yeah
so this is just like the other films as
you mentioned they're inspired by horror
films that sort of fit this genre
whether that might be the alien films
starring Sigourney Weaver or films like
event horizon the idea was sort of the
play up on the the claustrophobic spaces
of what it would be like for space
travelers whether you're actually on a
spaceship or in a facility that is sort
of keeping you alive while you're
dealing with the elements of some
unknown planet which is where we
actually happen to be in this episode so
yeah we're we're definitely keeping that
that movie feel alive just happened to
harken back to different films aside
from the things that we did in zombies
in space land so slightly less colorful
a little darker and just a little bit
creepier in some places and of course as
you've seen we've been fighting the
vicious cryptids which are making their
return from one of our first co-op
endeavors in Call of Duty extinction
mode the cryptids are back and they are
quite a force to reckon with so we're
gonna try and survive here long enough
to extinguish some of these cryptids and
hopefully restore that the facilities AI
and Power Systems here how many hours a
week do you think you get to play Call
of Duty oh man I play it quite a bit
more than people might assume part of
that is
you know I'm just play testing and
making sure that everything works one of
you guys that are playing with me I
think you guys can turn Neil's head on
if you can get to it but yeah we I spend
a lot of time playing the game and part
of it is just making sure that things
feel right whether it's a specific
weapon or one of the fate and fortune
cards that we're utilizing one of the
bosses that we're fighting so it's it's
really something that the team strive to
do every single day as we hit rate
through the process for constant playing
and then of course besides for myself
playing we bring people in from external
sources that help us make sure it feels
right to them as well because we were
not building this experience solely for
us this is a community effort that were
you know we're striving to make sure
that that everyone gets a chance to
enjoy this call of duty zombies
experience who is I think this is the
really interesting point
not something new but going to this
afterlife arcade to bring yourself back
into the game yeah and interestingly
enough I chose to play cryptid attack
and that's something that we introduced
way back in zombies in space land to
kind of plant the seed that these
cryptids were going to be making their
way back from extinction and into this
zombies endeavor enough I did that fast
enough we should be seeing zombies and
if I was too slow we're gonna be getting
one more round of cryptids which we
should be able to hang through in a big
part we got the zombies awesome good
work everybody
you guys like to plant the seeds of
things people are gonna be seeing in
these later episodes throughout the
entire game then I guess a lot of that's
gonna be paying off now in this final
episode yeah if you've been plenty if
you've been paying close attention we've
actually though the name for this
episode was sitting on a marquee sign
and attack of the radioactive thing it
was hidden in clean site and a lot of
people speculated no oh you know what's
what's the name of that gonna be is
gonna be this is gonna be that a lot of
people thought we were just gonna title
it extinction but ultimately we've kind
of done this over and over and over
again even attack of the radioactive
thing we had a comic book that was
hiding in Shaolin shuffle that if you
collected that comic book you would see
that we were clearly telling you what
you were gonna fight what the name of
the episode was going to be like and
those kind of things so if it's
something that we love to do we love to
hide things in plain sight and then also
drop information really early
that you might not pay really close
attention to but find out that it's
ultra relevant later on down the road so
go through the the Pacific I haven't
jumped in myself yet but I don't
immediately recognize anything as a
direct dommage to any specific films is
there anything that you would call out
is like what you drew inspiration from
for anything in the in this map yeah
absolutely so I really love some of the
more classic horror films so like the
thing as an example having that eye
setting knowing that you can't just run
and leave this facility because
otherwise you'll just freeze to death
you know the elements will get you so
even even having that there's a little
bit of that that notion in there
obviously the cryptids when we created
them way back in extinction they were a
direct reaction to a lot of the the
alien types that we had seen in various
films whether that be Ridley Scott's
aliens or even little grey aliens like
et you know we wanted to we want to sort
of pay homage to that that that type of
alien creature the facility itself we
were kind of going for almost an event
horizon look I think a little less
bloody and horror sort of feeling but
the idea that clearly something has gone
wrong you know when you're seeing this
the cement and debris sort of blown open
and holes created here this doesn't look
like it's something that was made
intentionally and the fact that the
facility itself is sort of in lockdown
mode we see you know rough barricades
where no wooden boards and things are
trying to hold things out clearly
something has gone very wrong here and
with the film event horizon upon
boarding that ship immediately you can
kind of get that icky feeling like you
know what something's off and I should
probably watch my back
oh that's quite all right nukes are
always good are you so you're in a
facility in space right yep
where are you getting these wooden
boards from are these imported you know
what it's so I love that you asked that
question because we actually the
characters poke fun at the fact that the
wooden boards are still here in space so
at some of the video we actually have
some fun with the fact that some of the
mechanics while they're tried-and-true
mechanics to zombies they don't they
don't necessarily fit the theme 100% and
that's the thing that kind of makes the
characters go
we'll learn what's going on here what's
up with that will the wooden boards can
we can you get some steel reinforced
laser trap windows or something so yeah
we actually poked fun at ourselves for
that but it's also one of the staples of
zombies is knowing that you can walk up
to these windows that you can place
these boards you can get a little bit of
cash back and then feel safe for all of
10 seconds while the zombies rip them
down
free your mind I'm gonna see if we can
venture our way outside a little bit but
before we do them in a little cash in
here first so one of the things I'd like
to tell a lot of the players who are
struggling with the difficulty early on
is you might have noticed that our
success was really due to the fact that
we got the power on right away that we
didn't spend a lot of time exploring and
examining the world this this is gonna
be like getting thrown into a blender
right away so you've done it you've
gotta get the AI facility restored to
the Emile sort of supporting you and
shutting off the biological threat known
as the cryptids and also get the zombie
spawning in because they're a much
easier thing to deal with it will
reintroduce common gameplay themes like
being able to train the zombies in some
of these spaces like these open spaces
we have here are fantastic for training
and really getting some big kills and
then of course there's some awesome
traps to lead them through and that kind
of leads back to the question you were
asking about what did we use you know
films for as far as inspiration we have
a couple of different locations in here
where we have traps that are sort of
themed back to experiences that we had
seen in other other movies before so I
don't have the cash I'm about 60 short
but this hallway here which I'm gonna
open in just a second we've got a laser
laser trap that's reminiscent of
Resident Evil the movie near that moment
where the guy who tries to walk down the
hallway he jumps over the first laser
beam he ducks under the second one and
he does all this parkour stuff he's like
alright I survived it and all of a
sudden the Laser grid comes and he's
just diced to pieces so we're definitely
looking at things like that where we
seen in films where we see something
really cool cool ways for ways to be
mutilated decapitated whatever it may be
so the laser trap for Resident Evil the
film is something that we wanted to
bring back now it's not exactly like
that trap but it definitely gives the
feeling and and gives off the idea that
we might have seen that somewhere else
and another really big aspect of just
Ami's in general are the easter eggs
that you guys hide for us in it I assume
there's gonna be a lot of payoff in this
final episode where people finally get
to the root of these things that they
found yeah and I think that's something
that we really went all out on is art
Easter eggs you know we've we've built
the Easter eggs in many different ways
throughout the season we want to have
small things that people can kind of
pick up on just by looking around going
oh I recognize that from from some other
pop culture reference but also we want
to build the things that players really
enjoy digging deep in lifting every
stone and and and figuring out what's
underneath it and we've definitely built
that experience into it now of course
bees from beyond is gonna have all of
its awesome Easter eggs present but at
the same time there's something that
we've introduced in this episode that
players have been being teased about all
year long and that's our super Easter
egg known as the director's cut and what
the director's cut Easter Egg is is
we've sent players through collecting
these soul keys and now players have
always wondered what are the what are
the need what's the purpose for these
soul keys why do I need them and the
idea is that once you've collected the
soul keys you can actually unlock the
true form of these films and actually
really make changes in them and our
heroes that have been in these episodes
before us whether it's Kevin Smith or
Pam Grier or david hasselhoff they've
sort of referenced the fact that these
films are sort of like the easy versions
of the films and so directors kind is
going to introduce all new Easter eggs
it's going to allow some of the Easter
eggs that we've teased fans about like
the Yeti AI Easter Egg all the way back
in zombies at Spaceland
they're going to now be able to gain
access directly to those Easter eggs and
on top of that as you mentioned we are
definitely going to let players find out
what exactly is going on why has Willard
Wilder pulled these four heroes into
this film and ultimately what is going
to happen to them what's going to happen
to Willard all of us will get to find
out in the end do you feel like this is
the more challenging chapter that you
guys have released so far oh absolutely
this is the chapter that everything
we've taught you thus far has been a
learning lesson for what you're going to
face in this episode so in each of the
episodes we've introduced new creature
types
obviously different boss strategies and
ways to play the game you'll need to
understand and know all of those
different tactics in order to survive
the beast from beyond so I've just made
my way back into the theatre and this is
a place that fans have always wanted to
go there's me looking back at the beast
from beyond I've made my way literally
out of the screen and the trick is going
something to kill him and this actually
brings us back into Willard's theatre
the very theatre that he pulled us into
zombies and space land initially we've
now made our way into and we're actually
able to fight in this space which is a
pretty interesting thing now the scary
part about that is all of these films
featured in Willard's terrible library
unfortunately are now able to be
released and so by opening up this space
I've actually opened up the theaters for
zombies in space land attack of the
radioactive thing challenge shuffle all
of the episodes actually some of their
best
or should I say some of their worst
enemies are going to come forward so the
slasher from Raven you were terrified of
that guy he's back if you were afraid of
the kung-fu zombies and Shaolin shuffle
those guys have made their return we
have the exploding clowns from zombies
in space line have made their return so
there's lots of different things that
are basically going to be thrown in the
players face as we like to say the
kitchen sink is being thrown at you this
time around so everything you've learned
you'll really need to use it now not
only just specifically for this episode
but like I talked about in that super
Easter egg whatever is waiting for you
at the end of that you will need
everything and then some to survive
what's waiting ahead so you'll need all
this training we promise we've made it
hard for a very good reason
they said the overall theme for this
zombies expansion has seemed to be kind
of more I guess light-hearted I would
say in some ways well more a fun take on
that zombies world what's it been like
working in that kind of environment like
where did the those ideas come to me
well it's definitely a team effort you
know we sit down and try to figure out
what it is we want to do what are what
are our challenges that we want to put
in front of ourselves and ultimately
overcome one of my or some of my
favorite films one of them being an
American world from London and another
one being Shaun of the Dead - probably
my my all-time favorite horror films
they're all so spliced with a lot of
comedy and I like the fact that you can
have a world that's having a very
serious event take place but at the same
time there's a very light-hearted
approach and you saw this even though
films like zombie land as well where the
characters are kind of able to pop jokes
in between sort of these moments of
desperation trying to survive this
really like terrible situation and I
mean that we're playing games we want to
have fun that everything doesn't have to
be ultra serious while we have a serious
lair that's sort of hidden underneath
all of that within our story and what's
taking place we also wanted to have some
fun we have some really great talent
that are comedians themselves Jay
Pharoah so she rose and Maeda are
they're amazing stand-up comedians
themselves and so bringing them into a
really serious tone while they're there
acting range can certainly support it
their strengths are certainly in comedy
and so we wanted to play up on upon the
strength of those characters as well as
bring a light-hearted approach that I
think is a very welcoming thing to a
much larger audience than I would say a
very serious approach to zombies where
you might have to say hey you know kids
go to bed this is gonna be a little bit
too scary for you our zombies is a
little less scary it's definitely very
serious but at the same time it's also
one of those experiences that
it's not so terrible it's not so
gruesome and awful that everyone needs
to stay away or or put the kids to bed
early and thinking about coming up with
this number were you able to or was the
team able to to iterate on ideas or to
be able to get see that feedback from
the audience and maybe change some
things that might have felt like they
weren't going in the right direction
wait especially now coming to this final
chapter oh absolutely I mean I think
we're always doing that one of the
things that we've done and we've strived
really hard for this this entire season
with zombies is we wanted to be really
engaged with the audience we wanted to
get out there be on Twitter being reddit
chime in on YouTube streams and really
make it a point that we were really
letting fans know that we were listening
though that this was just as much their
game as it is ours I mean ultimately
like I said earlier we don't create
these titles for ourselves we're
creating this for a large audience and
people and so you know we want to hear
what people think about the product
whether it's something that they they
love or whether it's something that they
just find to be distasteful or they just
flat-out don't like and we'd like to
challenge them with can you tell us why
what is it about that experience that we
could do differently or or just alter
just a little bit that would actually
draw you in and make you more of a fan
and we've had moments within development
where we've certainly course-corrected
you know initially we had our UFO fight
our a lien granzymes in space land was I
think set at a bar that we thought
here's where the core zombies player
wanted to be playing it they wanted to
be playing at this really high bar but
we also wanted to get a lot of new
players in because while a lot of people
play zombies everyone on the planets not
playing it and ultimately that's our
goal we want to get everybody in the
world playing the game if we possibly
can so we wound up toning that fight
down a little bit so that we can get
more people engaged it was also a little
counterintuitive to the fact that we had
built in a tutorial and sort of a system
that sort of guided players through the
experience a little bit in the beginning
and then at the end of it it was like
alright now we're gonna make these
really hard so we course-corrected that
a little bit we wanted making that fight
just a tad bit easier balancing it a
little bit more and that was direct
feedback that we received from the
community a lot of people were getting
to that fight and saying you know I just
can't I can't beat this thing I really
like your game but I really want to be
get through this experience and so
ultimately we wanted making some minor
adjustments there and then of course
while we're going through the season
we're introducing new content which
we've done all year long we have a bunch
of new content that comes free of charge
to players that are long for the ride
with us so when we release fate and
fortune cards those cards are backwardly
compatible with all the previous
experiences so we released two new fate
and fortune cards in this map alongside
this map skull hacker and packing heat
and skull hacker allows you to complete
will not necessarily complete but jump
to the endgame of one of our biggest
Easter eggs which is our ghost installs
arcade machine where you literally
become a player inside the game and then
pack and heat allows you to double pack
a punch a random weapon into your hand
it could be a Wonder weapon it could be
just a regular OSA it could be any
weapon that ends up in your hand double
pack now in zombies in space land the
ability to double pack your weapon early
on wasn't available to you so you could
never fight the alien grey with a double
time weapon now with that card spotted
in your hand and you can actually have a
weapon that you could take that alien
gray on right out of the gate from the
beginning of the game so those are just
some examples of ways that we've added
additional layers of support to fans so
that they can actually get through this
this experience and then last but not
least the director's cut content that we
created for players that are able to
make it through that content they're
gonna be rewarded handsomely you know
we're gonna give them the things that
they've been asking for players have one
of the ability to have per call it - to
have these these ways to sort of play
the game where they're in control of the
outcome of what's happening in that
sandbox and so we're gonna put that
power back into the players hands and
allow them to have just a little bit
more fun by being able to go back to
zombies in space land or Raven the red
was there any of those other maps and
sort of have new experiences but at the
same time be a little bit more empowered
in those experiences and hopefully take
a couple of their friends along for the
ride that weren't able to survive maybe
the first time around so as director's
cut aimed more at that core really
skilled audience er do you feel like the
skill cap is low enough that the best
offers on the forever
I think it's I think it's pointed at
both and it's a combination of whether
it's skill or whether it's you know
using things to your advantage so
whether it's using specific fortune
cards or if it is using the weapon kits
to upgrade your weapons whether you're
upgrading them in MPE or in zombies
throughout the season we've continuously
continued to empower the player so I
think by the time we get to the end of
this and you know we have director's cut
players playing with the non director's
cut players we have all the the various
fate and fortune cards available all the
weapons are unlocked to players there's
gonna be quite a bit of power and quite
an arsenal in our fans hands so we were
able to restore the power we've got our
zombies that are gonna be spawning on us
now how long does a full run-through
this generally take you at this point oh
that's a great question when you have a
better team than if you if you know how
to do everything if you know where
everything is
obviously the boss fight itself is gonna
be challenging I'd say it's probably
gonna take you about an hour to an hour
and a half to get through all of the
content and that's that's about the
average of all of our zombie C's
experiences it could be anywhere from an
hour to two hours depending on your
skill level and depending on how how
fast you sort of progress some of the
Easter eggs but again that director's
cut contents gonna reopen this content
for you and give you some new things to
explore so to go through everything all
episodes plus the director's cut content
I think players are looking at dozens
and dozens and dozens of hours of
content to consume which is ultimately
what we wanted to do we wanted to make
sure that we we went out with a really
big bang with this this last deals here
with the hippies from beyond are you sad
to be leaving it behind like now this is
this is the the end of a really long
journey yeah you know I think I feel a
little bit of that with every project
that I complete I've been in the game
industry a long long time now and I
think with every title that you sort of
put on the shelf and leave it to chill
you look back on it you think of all the
challenges that you faced and overcame
you think of all the the new things that
you were able to introduce and bring to
the table so yeah there's a little bit
of sadness but then I think there's also
a little bit of excitement of
you know we did this thing what are we
gonna do next what is the next thing
that we're gonna do and so I think I
know myself and my team we're both we're
all really excited about getting to our
next endeavor but also making sure that
what we do here leaves a really good
memory and a really good taste in
people's mouths so that the next time
they come around and want to play our
content they go hey I remember what
those guys did and they're they're
excited to jump back in with us
yeah it's not like people have a long
time to wait for even more zombies
content because we have another ecology
world war two coming up yes you've
gotten to play much of their zombie
stuff I have and they have some really
great ideas some really great concepts
going on I think people will be very
excited once they get their hands on
World War two whether it's the the
amazing campaign those guys have built
or the really awesome multiplayer for
those of you that have played the beta
and played war you know what I'm talking
about and then definitely their zombies
experience is going to continue the
theme of getting players to play
cooperatively together in a really
challenging experience all the things
that you've come to know and love with
zombies whether it be digging for Easter
eggs or high round survival us just like
them that experience is built for those
players and those fans are definitely
kept in mind oh yeah how is that that
work on the development side because
there is that trade-off of Call of Duty
and you think of that as like I think in
a lot of ways is the multiplayer in the
campaign but zombies has become such an
integral part of that as well but it
feels like there's also a lot of
institutional knowledge how do you share
that between teams when you do that
trade off to the next the VEX group
who's gonna be making this well I think
it's really dependent on the team I
think some teams tend to be a little
more isolated and we're one of those
groups for sure we built this zombies
experience without the support of
sledgehammer or Treyarch this was all
done by the Infinity Ward zombies team
so it really depends on how much you
want to reach out now that's not to say
that we don't share tech because we do
share you know an engine that we run our
games across and there's there certainly
some of that that sort of crosses the
aisle but I think for the most part the
studios are fairly independent they come
up with their own concepts of concepts
on ideas and each of us are trying to
push you know push the envelope just a
little bit more
last one and so there's a little bit of
that competitive nature where we want to
one-up them they want to one-up us and
ultimately the only person that that
really wins here is the fans and that's
really who should be winning you know
they poured their their money into our
pockets and you know they're pouring
their time into our product and so we
want to pour everything we've got into
creating a great compelling experience
and I don't think that differs between
us or Treyarch or sledgehammer or
whoever got that at the current helm for
releasing that version of Call of Duty
down here is there a particular
highlight that really stands out for
from you guys on what you've created
with this version of zombies you're like
yeah no one else is gonna be able to
touch that hmm I would I would love to
say that but you know honestly I think I
think we all strive to do to do awesome
new stuff and bring you know great new
content to the table for us I think it's
a culmination of a lot of different
ideas you know we sort of strove for not
only making a an experience that was
true to the zombies experience you know
this is a round based thing you know
you're fighting hordes and hordes of
zombies you know there are the hidden
easter eggs and all those things that
sort of stay true to it but we also
wanted to go for quality of life
improvements you know one of the things
that we're we're super proud of you know
this hats off to our engineers at
Infinity Ward but our game never you
never see a loading screen there's no
point in which you have to stop and
stare at a loading screen in order to
get back into the game and that's
something that we're really proud of
that we were able to achieve with this
game the other thing is our afterlife
arcade we want to keep players engaged
all the time so when you die you have
something to do you're not just staring
and watching at your teammate playing
and sort of filling his highlight reel
or her highlight reel so you know it's
it's all of those little touches all the
little additions that we made whether
it's walking up to a perk machine and
being able to drop the perk that you
have so that you can pick up and switch
to a different perk the type of Easter
eggs that we built whether it be the
really small things that pay homage to
movies or films or television shows but
then also those really deep rooted
Easter eggs that get sort of crowdsource
by the whole community where everyone's
pouring their their thoughts into you
know how to uncover how to you know
figure out what this last thing might be
so yeah I think we're always looking for
for something great and if I had to pick
any one thing I would definitely say
it's all of the iterative iterative
designs that we've had from previous
ventures into zombies the way that we've
approached fighting bosses or the way
that we've approached dealing with
special waves or Easter eggs or any of
those things so I think it's the
culmination of all of those ideas that
sort of make up this this different
thing even even our cinematics our
cinematic
cartoons versus being you know
computer-generated images it really sets
us apart I think when people look at our
game and look at sledges next endeavor
they're gonna clearly see that this was
an infinite warfare and World War two
definitely is not that game it is a
completely different experience is it
have you guys been crunching pretty hard
to to finish this up or has it been kind
of a more leisurely because you're used
to this now you guys have I'm sure a
well-oiled machine of getting this
content out but is there still that
crunch every time you have right before
a new episode comes out I definitely
think there's a bit of a crunch whenever
you're putting content out and I think
really that comes down to the developers
want this to be the best thing that they
can possibly have fans received so we
crunch pretty hard we're a pretty small
team my my a zombie's team is actually
much smaller than I would say any of the
other zombies to be working at the other
Studios and so because we are a smaller
team we do we do have to be a well-oiled
machine but you know the benefit that we
have is this team has been working
together
harkening back all the way to extinction
and even titles before working on Call
of Duty whether it be Guitar Hero or
Tony Hawk games when we were at
Neversoft so yeah I think there's a
point where you reach for you kind of
know what your team is thinking what
everybody's sort of gelled upon and
making decisions can be really easy when
you can look left you can look right and
everyone sort of automatically on the
same page so yeah you do have to be a
well-oiled machine to get this content
out as fast as we do but then also as
content richest
- I don't think anyone can argue that
our content hasn't been crammed Oh
just to the max as much as we could
possibly get everything in we've
certainly tried whether it be like I
said small little tiny Easter eggs or
the really really big tough ones to have
our QA team go through and make sure
they all work and function so that way
when they release people aren't hit with
game-breaking bugs which unfortunately
you know what happens and so the beauty
of the way that games have sort of
blossomed into the future present day is
that you can actually have a
gamebreaking issue and tomorrow it's
fixed it's patched and that's an amazing
thing so you know as much as we'd like
to make sure every single little thing
works the the audience out number is my
QA team by quite a large margin and so
some of the things they find we might
have attempted to uncover some of those
things but the challenges is that we
face with with testing every single
scenario
unfortunately leave some stones unturned
which means we have to we have to be
agile in the sense that we have to
course-correct and make changes even
post ship of some of our content I
remember when there was so much
trepidation around that always online
world and now I feel like that's almost
accepted as that's the way things are
like I did people welcomed that because
it does give you immediate access to
fixes to to more content
I couldn't imagine the world without it
I grew up playing you know SNES NES Sega
Master System all the classic stuff and
I couldn't imagine what it would have
been like to be able to add new levels
to Super Mario Brothers 3 I would I
would have bought that DLC in a
heartbeat you know what it would have
been like to have an online experience
of a game like Tetris or super contra or
any of those things where you could just
jump in and and play with your friends
now the infancy of of what online was I
remember I had my my sacred Sega Saturn
with my 28 eight modem and I was playing
fantasy star and I can't remember what
games I was playing but it was it was an
experience where if someone picked up
the phone you were disconnected you know
it was dial-up all this up so where we
are today these sort of the advent of
gaming today where you can have gigs of
data downloaded to a machine
and have new content man I couldn't I
just I couldn't imagine going back this
is this is a great time for gaming and
the digital the digital stuff I I buy so
much digital content at this point and
it's so convenient especially you know
if you're if you're playing in different
places you know I have a ps4 at my house
I have a ps4 in my office but I also
want to play the same content I don't
want to necessarily have to abandon that
content because I didn't bring a disc
with me so being able to log in at one
place and log in at another and pick up
where I left off has just been an
absolutely wonderful thing to have
happen to video games I remember my
shareware copy of Castle Wolfenstein and
you have to like I like I didn't even to
unlock the game you would have to answer
a question about it would ask you
something from the manual like I don't
have manual so I'm just eventually I
would you it would make enough sense or
I would be able to figure something out
because it was also before there was
enough stuff on the internet for you to
go to a page and find out what those
work yes the game you had to just figure
out what yes sort it's looking and
everything needed a strategy guide there
was no go to youtube and watch my
favorite youtube streamer and and
they're basically painting exactly the
golden path for me and what I need to do
and where I need to go so that's a
that's a really lovely thing too and
then the other thing you know the social
media aspect of games and even the fact
that you have a lot of these features
sort of pre baked into the consoles now
where your ps4 can stream to switch and
have all this content out there it
really has just revolutionized the way
people look at gaming I mean I find my
son going on YouTube and literally
watching people just play content all
the time and it's amazing how engaged he
is with some of the videos where he's
like I just want to uncover this one
little secret that I can't and then he
finds himself in the game he's like yes
I'm celebrating this thing that I
finally achieved so that's a it's a
really amazing time for gaming
absolutely amazing hey you got a chance
to watch it by going with that horror
theme
so it was supposed to be on my watch
list this weekend but unfortunately
Southern California was randomly struck
by thunderstorms in my area and our our
power was out and so our theater our
local IMAX which is where I wanted to
see it unfortunately was having these
sort of rolling blackouts take place so
it is on my to-do list this week so
please no spoilers in my inbox for those
of you that have seen it I've heard it
was very good very scary and I see that
it's breaking box-office numbers but
please no spoilers to mr. Ross Hey so
dude do movies and things like that that
are coming out now does that make you
does that give you any inspiration for
your next project because obviously this
isn't gonna be the the end in for you do
you look at that kind of stuff and think
like you know what could we do next what
could we what kind of elements could I
add to my next project absolutely all
the time and I think we I think that's
an everyday life I think you're you walk
around and you you see things where you
say wow that would be cool in the game
that's not something that's in our game
now but if we had that that would
actually be interesting even some of the
concepts that we come up with for what a
weapon can do sometimes you see
something silly like we see a Dyson
vacuum commercial and all of a sudden
you're like I could see this doing
something like this and although it's
not a Dyson vacuum I'm gonna run around
with I could probably see something else
behaving like this so yeah I think
there's there can be inspiration found
in all all walks of life when it comes
to game development whether it's movies
TV whether it's real-world experiences I
mean the team before we built zombies in
space land one of our reference trips
was to actually go out and go to a theme
park and we chose to go to Knott's Scary
Farm in Southern California where they
were having their Halloween event and it
was such it was such an amazing
experience because you know they build
all these these haunted house
experiences where things are jumping out
at you and and people are dressed as
scary clowns and things like that and
it's absolute inspiration when you look
at that you say wow this is actually
cool because people are doing this in
real life so if we put this in the game
it's got to make sense right and a lot
of times it does a lot of times it just
it just fits I was gonna ask if if you
guys do a lot of those kind of group
trips you do you have like here's the
day when we're all gonna watch the thing
and you
gonna see for anybody who hasn't seen it
before - to understand the kind of feel
that we're going for with this remote
station set in an ice I think I don't
necessarily I wouldn't necessarily say
that we do it all as a group but
independently it is something that we
find ourselves doing where we'll say
this is something you should pay
attention to check out this piece of
content from this thing of that thing
that is absolutely something where
someone will say hey I just saw this
particular movie or watch this show and
it has this this moment in it watch this
thing and tell me what you think about
it so we do find that we pass media back
and forth to each other where you know
whether it be a movie or TV show or
whatever it might be yeah we're
definitely in sync when it comes to
stuff like that has there been anything
that you've discovered the front from
your team that you just weren't aware of
before working on a project like this
from the team themselves yeah like
somebody it's something somebody's
introduced you to that you're like oh
wow that's this really cool I I wish
that I had seen this earlier my team has
introduced me to their insanity because
they're an absolutely crazy Bunch and I
love them for it because they are the
only group that makes me feel at home
because I'm pretty insane myself so yeah
pushing the boundaries of what we think
we can view what our what we thought we
could do when we went into some of these
experiences I mean just stepping back
into Raven the redwoods where you you
have sort of these this multicolored
rave world or Shaolin shuffle where it's
this this alternate universe of New York
City these are ideas that come up from
the entirety of the team this is not
just me or or any other one person that
decides all of this stuff
we do it as a group and I think that's
that's what's really special about it is
how much we trust each other how much we
rely on other to come up with great
content you know whether it be my art
director jgeiger telling us this is why
the skybox should be a certain color or
this is why the heroes should wear these
types of outfits
it just it comes it comes from
everywhere so in each of the episodes we
did find out that some people were a
little bit passionate about more things
than others come to find out our project
director Brian bright is a pretty
awesome breakdancer and also used to
rave quite a bit back in the day
and so protip if you look at the Raven
the Redwoods ravers that's actually
motion capture Brian bright Brian I'm so
sorry to tell people that but I had to
have to let that cat out the bag so yeah
I mean it's little things that you pick
up like that our art director Jake IRA
who I mentioned earlier turns out that
he is a huge huge Star Trek fan so
coming into space he was very excited to
do that but at the same time you'll
actually notice that there are
references to Star Trek itself like
Andre is wearing a red outfit and in
Star Trek red outfit usually means
you're the first person to die and of
course we wound up writing that into the
script and talking about hey how come on
we're in the red shirt you guys want to
do a wardrobe change real quick so it's
things like that I think we all we all
sort of bring a little bit of magic and
craziness to the table that helps make
these experiences come to life
so we probably have room our time - for
one more run through this hopefully
we're a little more successful I'm sorry
that our team is not helping you out at
all oh we're doing we're actually doing
pretty good I played three public lap
matches last night right before going to
bed and the first team I ran with we
just we died repeatedly and I think the
biggest issue is that we had no one on
microphone people just kind of scattered
around going crazy and trying to face
the cryptids the same way that they
would face the zombies and as you can
see I can kind of chill and look at this
guy for a while lead him around but if I
see a cryptid that cryptic can get to me
and you have to you have to face them a
lot differently so the fact that we were
able to survive the first round get the
power restored and sort of explore the
facility I'm pretty impressed with I
feel like that's always a challenge with
multiplayer games is that you do it's
easier it's more fun when you're with
friends and you're able to coordinate
over microphones but you also have to
balance it for for people who don't who
maybe don't have a microphone or just
are jumping into random matches with
other people how do you how do you
strike that balance yeah that's it
that's a great point you know first and
foremost this is a cooperative
experience and so we build that
experience first you know the ideas that
we realize the most fun you're gonna
have is you know playing with three of
your buddies gram three of your family
members whoever and going through that
experience as a team feels the best and
so we want that experience to feel
really good at the same time we also
want to make sure that you know someone
who just wants to play on their couch by
themselves on a Saturday night and
they're just gonna hang out and enjoy
themselves we want to make sure that all
of our Easter eggs and this is this is
true to everything we've made every
single Easter egg that we place in the
game can be completed whether
cooperatively or in solo so this is
built and balanced for every single
experience whether you're playing a solo
mash a two-player match a three player
match or four player it's this is
designed for you to have a good time no
matter what that that combination of
players is and like I said we also want
to make sure that there's no content
that's out of reach simply because you
don't have a friend to play with or a
partner to team up with at the time so
everything that you can see in the
cooperative experience you can also have
those experiences in solo as well
and the balancing is always tough the
balancing is always one of those things
that right down to the wire we're making
changes based off of last minute
feedback on whether it's weapon
balancing whether it's fate and fortune
cards whether it's how much cash you
earn versus how much you have to spend
to open up doors to get to power it's a
it's a constant juggling match for us to
find the right equation that gets people
ultimately I have a smile on their face
because it's not just the number of
enemies that necessarily make it more
difficult we have the types and then
what's available to you as a player
exactly exactly that and in this one
since now that we're in this space we
are actually gonna have all the
different types that we had talked about
so you'll notice that the zombies aren't
there necessarily wearing spacesuits
anymore you'll start to see the 80s
themed zombies the 90s thing zombie doll
making their way through here as well
see it is it is all the different types
and of course each time we introduce one
of these maps we always have this
special types and this in this
particular instance is think it's the
cryptids we've only seen one handful of
the cryptids and there's definitely
other types and other versions of them
which are far worse than ones who can
face it so far but there's also all the
different zombies types so we might be
lucky enough to survive long enough to
start seeing some some clowns who might
survive long enough to see some ravers
there somewhere the ravers and some
other really terrible guys have made the
return like the slasher from raping the
redwoods so yeah balancing this map for
all those different types has been quite
a challenge but we feel like we got it
to a really sweet spot and we hope fans
are having a really good time facing the
challenge we presented them with thus
far give any particular fears
is there anything like making this kind
of thing you're like I didn't really
want to make clowns oh you know what
that wasn't that certainly wasn't me I
saw Stephen King's it when it was a
television series and I although very
frightening clowns were never my my
thing my fear is actually something we
haven't played with much here is Heights
I just I'm not a fan of like people who
mountain climb with with no rope and
things like that like just watching that
stuff makes me
feel uneasy we did play with verticality
a little bit in fact we introduced that
in the trailer that and the fact that in
this map we have a few different height
variants as you're going through the
facility there's cases where you could
be on the third floor and jump down two
floors and we wanted to play around that
because that's something that you don't
get to do very often zombies it's
something especially with the boots on
the ground experience you're pretty much
on a single plane all the time but this
was that was a case where we wanted to
get players sort of moving around
through the space just a little bit
differently than we normally had yeah
Heights are something that I feel like
you can you really experience that at
something like VR yes like that's
something that can really touch on that
fear a zombie VR experience really
awesome
hey have you gotten to play much VR I
think another big horror game that we
had earlier this year Resident Evil 70
did that to a really great effect but it
feels like that might be harder to
accomplish but something like Call of
Duty like when you're moving really fast
when you're shooting a lot yeah I think
I think for Call of Duty it could work
but but it it's also the expectation of
how VR as an application is handled part
of it is that you're usually stationary
but you need to be able to have some
amount of movement you know I have I
have an HTC vive at home which I've
played a tremendous amount of and really
enjoy it requires a decent amount of
movement because the first thing we
realized my wife and my kids at home we
realized that we swing our arms quite
wildly when we play VR and we bang into
televisions and knock speakers off the
wall and all that kind of stuff so you
have to you have to build the experience
for the format and I think VR has a very
specific way that it's played current in
its current iteration I think it will
certainly find its way or at least I
hope that if it finds its way along the
lines of one of the books I read this
year ready player one where we sort of
have this virtual world where you don't
go to school but you put your VR goggles
on and you sit in your classroom kind of
experience so but the current iteration
I think requires players to kind of be a
little more stationary and then also
people don't do well at least from what
I've seen my experiences with
I've seen play VR they don't really do
well with being moved in a vr space so
walking through a hallway or going up
and down an elevator tends to get people
feeling nauseous so I think that's the
challenges one of the challenges that
developers have to sort of come to grips
with is how do we get this experience to
feel as real and awesome as this
experience as where I'm moving around
I'm dipping and dodging and trying to
survive but in a VR format I think
that's an awesome challenge for anyone
who's gonna be taking that on but I do
think it is something that you won't
necessarily get exactly what you have
now be really curious if movie isn't
worth like some more experiences just
took advantage of it I think video games
are a great medium and it makes a lot of
sense but it feels like doing some more
experimental and different things could
be yeah absolutely I think you know we
we dabbled in the VR experience with
Call of Duty when we first shipped
infinite warfare and there was the the
VR mode where you could fly the Jackal
around and that was a really awesome
experience because part of what I was
mentioning earlier about that that
getting sick feeling is that moving
through tunnels through hallways in our
VR experience because you're in the
cockpit you sort of have something caged
around you you feel like the thing
around you is moving not necessarily
that your body is moving and I think
that separation of of your body and your
eyes you know looking one way and
feeling if you're going to go one way
but your body is actually going in a
different direction was solved a lot
because you were inside of a ship so I
think experiences like that
self-contained experiences like that I
think that's the infancy of where VR is
ultimately gonna go but I'm excited for
the future of what it can be for gaming
VR and AR for that matter I could see a
combination sort of a combination of the
two really making video games feel like
a completely different experience than
what we were seeing five years ago ten
years ago in definitely 20 or 30 years
ago I mean kind of as we saw from Apple
today that they're doing a really big
push into augmented reality on their
passes yeah I think AR has some
definitely there's definitely some
interesting applications where AR really
shines but just like with VR I think
it's
it's infancy and we've got to allow it
to have all people have to take chances
you have to take chances on the medium
and really I think with any format
it just takes money really great idea it
takes one really great piece of
execution that pushes everyone into the
right direction
I've seen it on platforms like the
Nintendo 64 you just needed Super Mario
64 to show people this is how you move
in a 3d environment I think that's what
VR needs VR needs its killer app you
know the game boy when it first shipped
it had Tetris and all it took was Tetris
to tell people hey you should play games
outside of your house this is a great
idea and now people are playing games on
their phone every single day as if it's
just it's not a big deal went back in
the day it was to $189 for a gameboy and
another you know $30 per Tetris and you
know carrying a bad extra batteries
around and all these things and now all
of a sudden you have all of that just
sitting on your phone waiting for you to
attack whenever you want so I look I
can't tell I'm a huge video game nerd
and I love the evolution of the industry
and I'm really excited to see where
things are ultimately headed how are we
doing on time
the grow cams huh we'll see I think the
rest of your team is dead though I think
they are I think they're all afterlife
really I was just gonna say I did want
to touch a little bit more on the
director's cut content that I talked
about earlier we are putting a big sort
of sign on the wall for people to know
that this thing exists we don't want
this to be something that is so hidden
that only a small portion of the
community finds we wanted this to be
something that was built for everyone
who's playing the game so some of the
things I had mentioned earlier before
playing ghosts and skulls I know that
was a really tough challenge for people
to get through but there was some really
awesome reward sitting at the end of
those those ghosts and skulls rewards
are actually going to be applied to the
director's cut content so when you play
for director's cut you'll actually be
able to recover some of those powers
when you go back in and playing the
traditional game so starting with a
perco holic or starting with a wonder
weapon like one of the Spaceland zappers
is something that the director's cut
fans will get a chance to take part in
it and of course as I mentioned all new
Easter eggs all new Khan
and hidden behind the director's cut and
then I teased it before and I will say
on on-camera today there is more than
one ending to this game we built more
than one ending because there's a lot of
information that we want you to sort of
explore and and come to grips with so
that when you get to that you go oh now
I can see the methods of the madness
Infinity Ward Touche well so thanks so
much for joining us
going through the this final chapter in
the the zombies adventure for call of
duty infinite warfare and this is
available right now it came out earlier
today right yeah right now for ps4 fans
and then not too long we promise Xbox
and PC players you guys will get a
chance to have the cryptids tear your
faces off too they're waiting for you we
promise and if you have the season pass
of course you have access to this
immediately but this is also a
standalone thing with the latest DLC
package yeah absolutely so if you wanted
to just grab just this piece of content
you can absolutely do that it comes with
four awesome MP maps you get yourself a
dynamic PlayStation 4 theme that has an
awesome cryptic background that fades in
and out which is super cool and then of
course the beast from beyond the finale
to this season of zombies for me yeah so
it sounds like this is a great way to
whet your appetite especially for people
who are excited for their next Call of
Duty adventure with World War 2 here's
something to do in the meantime yes a
little bit more zombies Lee Ross again
thanks so much for joining us and I was
Justin hey Walt and that was called duty
zombies have a good rest of the day
[Music]
you